Hey fast and furious - we're doing a  roll PID let's go oh hey that's the  American that is a blooper right there  that is for you people  haha oh wait no you said it was too dark  you said it was too dark I'm driving  with no hands that was a no-no we can't  we don't know which cops are bought off  and which ones aren't we tell them our  guys the drivers for Romulo bastard so  fast Lima - five subject headed for Pepe  yeah well I'll be talking it down over  here hey fellas  no that's sucked  yeah what do you think is underneath the  hood just making me laugh Eliana Fidel  give us up on top there was that bother  when the hell is both of it gym again  Hey oh I'm sorry oh we got it  oh man this is so ridiculous I like the  way they're clowns yeah  oh damn good [ __ ] talent but you need  to get out my way homeboy  I'm a little pissed right now because  I'm not as mad as I was earlier Wow  [Music]